[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
léo est un génie c'est un génie un génie
et son oncle est un génie mais si
c'est le meilleur joueur du monde point
final histoire d'amour entre le barça et
messi qui ne s'arrêtera jamais
c'est un diamant un monstre selon moi
est ce qu'il est complet le meilleur
joueur du monde mais pour à mon humble
opinion pour nous c'est un héros pour
moi c'est le meilleur joueur de tous les
temps le meilleur joueur de tous les
temps il a un don spécial c'est le
meilleur joueur que j'ai jamais vu ce
gamin est un extraterrestre il est
illuminé
j'adorais être à sa place pendant 5
secondes
pour connaître cette sensation
je m'appelle lionel messi j'ai 13 ans je
joue avant centre
bonsoir bienvenue bonsoir entrée je vous
en prie
[Musique]
merci
à regarder voilà cruijff
merci le patron de l' orange mécanique
de 1974 le meilleur joueur hollandais
elle nous invite à valdano la champion
du monde 1986
a été une révolution d'abord parce que
c'était un joueur fantastique et ensuite
comme entraîneur quand ils entraient sur
le terrain c'était du délire comme
menotti ici
j'y crois pas menotti le maigre c'est
génial c'était mon idole l'entraîneur de
78 quand as tu rencontré léo pour la
première fois johan jours
c'était un gamin c'est vrai presque un
enfant ton premier souvenir j'étais en
maternelle le spectacle le spectacle le
carnaval en maternelle il était en
chantier
regardez cette photo oui je me souviens
2 dommage j'ai pas mes lunettes
et soit en sixième on dirais plutôt
qu'il est en cm1 oui je crois que c'est
ça c'est symbian os incroyable il ya
aussi aux haltères regarder et c'était
un spectacle d'école vous avez la même
tête aux
cadors les photos où on est tous les
quatre cantons et bébé
nous mère était si jeune elle avait
notre âge d'apporter 250 mille photos il
était minuscule
il était en pompier et moi aux
demoiselles il était déguisé en escargot
non pas cette fois ils étaient en
escargot au cp au cp face et la
maternelle était en escargot dans un
spectacle en 93 et oui hélas joueur le
plus rapide du monde en escargot j'avais
jamais fait le rapprochement on avait
mis en scène un conte je me souviens
c'était un enfer de faire participer
lionel il se cachait dans son costume il
était tellement mignon c'est vrai
c'était vraiment un chouette spectacle
tout le monde a adoré j'étais en grillon
du toit aux papillons le lutin rouge le
lutin rouge c'était un lutin les enfants
s'étaient débrouillés seuls on avait
fait du beau travail lionel avait
beaucoup participé
c'est un souvenir de la journée des
enseignants
les enfants nous avaient apporté des
fleurs et des cadeaux
ce jour là les eaux était allé chez sa
grand mère il avait détruit toutes les
plantes en jouant avec pablo se sont
presque uniquement de bons souvenirs
parce qu on était toujours ensemble
souvient en maternelle à la récré les
eaux s'emparait du ballon n'importe où
impossible de la récupérer les autres
enfants disait maîtresse donnez nous un
autre ballon on peut pas jouer avec
intel comment ça s'est passé comment tu
commencé à jouer
j'ai joué dans un club du quartier
il paraît qu'il a commencé grâce à sa
grand mère oui je crois que c'est vrai
c'est elle qui l'a fait jouer ce tel qu
il l messieurs je m'en souviens très
bien de sa grand mère maternelle ou
paternel
je ne sais plus sa grand mère maternelle
non
chatel je suis impatiente que tu es
quatre ans pour pouvoir t'emmener au
football parce que tu auras envie d'y
aller tous les jours quand tu verras
comme tes frères s'amuse bien tu voudras
t'inscrire mais tu dois attendre encore
deux ans comme rodrigo et mathias
exactement parce que tu es tout petit et
qu'ils sont grands mais dans deux ans tu
pourras jouer comme tes frères il paraît
que son frère rodrigo jouait très bien
vraiment en fait c'est rodrigo qui a
commencé et lionel allez le voir jouer
si tu sais quoi tu sera meilleur que et
tu sais pourquoi
parce qu'on ne sait jamais à quoi tu
penses et sa petite tête est un mystère
écoute moi bien mon petit chéri tu vas
devenir le plus grand joueur du monde
on y va
quel club de quartier grande dolly
les eaux je crois que l'entraîneur de
rodrigo la vue l'a vu mais je ne connais
pas bien l'histoire il faudrait qu'ils
nous la raconte ou et ce serait bien
mais se savait ce qui se passe c'est il
manque un joueur à grant holly c'est
idiot ne s'est pas réveillé je peux plus
attendre le match va commencer vous êtes
prêts oui on est prêt mais quel idiot
mamie je peux jouer tu veux jouer oui
je ne sais pas trop ce qu'elle a dit à
l'entraîneur du grand dole y écoutez moi
mon petit fils veut jouer non ils sont
trop grands pour lui qui sait jouer au
foot lui est très bien il était
tellement petit que personne ne croyait
en lui je sais pas il est petit tu as
quel âge presque six ans il court comme
une fusée tu sais pourquoi aucun nom
sont et rapide et bon je vais te mettre
sur l'ale aller en fils ce maillot et
bien joué à les bonhommes dépêche toi
fils
c'est le plus jeune des messi
6e zhu comme ses frères on a peut-être
une chance
vas-y méo montrent leur montre leur
aller
il a le ballon
laisse là
à
[Applaudissements]
c'est vraiment votre petit-fils bien
joué au yoyo
[Musique]
et là engagé et ça a été du délire avec
il récupérait le ballon il passait
plusieurs joueurs quand ils étaient à
grande eau lit je jouais à horizonte je
suis plus âgé je jouais dans la
catégorie supérieure il jouait comme un
dieu il passait tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
vous pouvez l'amener tous les après midi
à l'entraînement les autres à prendre en
quelque chose quand rodrigo mathias et
tous les grands étaient là bas ils ne
nous laissez pas joué elle est ou non
plus mais les on avait tellement envie
qu'il le laissait jouer disait blessé
paléo jouer il est trop petit on risque
de le blesser mais plus tard ils ont
avoué que c'était pour éviter la honte
de se faire dribbler par les eaux
la fameuse grand-mère l'histoire de la
grand mère elle l'encouragé quand la
cloche sonnait il était transformée il
attendait la récré pour sortir avec le
ballon et se mesurer aux autres classes
ils se battaient tous pour la voir viens
avec moi viens avec moi bien sûr
impossible de gagner sans lui ceux qui
choisissaient les eaux gagner on les
priver du ballon parce que ça provoquait
des disputes c'est vrai quand on lui
donnait pas le ballon il prenait une
bouteille en plastique il prenait des
sacs qu'il pourrait de papier il fallait
qu'il joue il a fini par fabriqués avec
des chiffons un très beau ballon qui a
bien résisté
il aimait jouer à tous les jeux mais
l'école ne l'intéressait pas beaucoup il
aimait d'autres shows il avait d'autres
centres d'intérêts s'il vous plaît ne me
fait pas prendre des matous des
espagnols laissez moi jouer au foot mais
s'il avait voulu il aurait pu étudier
aux personnes a dit le contraire mais on
avait un mal de chien à le faire
travailler en classe je me souviens que
célia l'avait menacé de lui interdire de
jouer au foot s'il ne faisait pas ses
devoirs et s'il ne prenait pas son bain
léo disait qu'il avait fait ses devoirs
que tout était ok merci
il s'asseyait toujours devant moi il
donnait un coup de pied dans ma chaise
quand il voulait quelque chose il
faisait une boulette de papier et il l'a
lancé on n'a jamais rien vu
sur le coup en tout cas ils étaient
voisins il était très amis comme frères
et soeurs on était si proche qu'on
pensait qu'on était cousin elle
s'occupait de tout il lui demande et
tours il utilisait sa voisine de pupitre
comme interprète avec le prof elle était
comme sa mère comme sa grande soeur
peint célia devait s'absenter elle le
déposer chez moi et maman la halle était
une fois on va laisser chez elle et
c'est elle qui m'a à l'été
il y a un mot pour ça comme maire non
comme ils étaient frères de lait frères
de l'est oui oui frères de l'est hé
ouais dans notre quartier quand les rues
étaient inondées quand les égouts
débordé on avait de l'eau jusqu'aux
genoux
on jouait au foot dans la fange en
risquant une affection
mon frère a un an de plus que moi
je me souviens de notre équipe la
machine de 87 quand on entrait sur le
terrain on était la seule équipe à
recevoir des bouts de papier on n'allait
pas directement au milieu du terrain
on se mettait en ligne sur le côté oui
sur le côté et les pères de mathias tôt
raul et d'autres nous jeter du papier on
avait l'impression de jouer devant 50000
personnes tu joues à quel poste j'étais
milieu avant centre avec lui et laisser
marquer oui c'est tout il me passait pas
grand chose mais bon tu étais plus
défensif je la lui prenait et je
marquais aussi
parfois être la piquer
quand on avait un problème du passé le
ballon et il trouver une solution
comment tu t'appelles diego riviera 2
quelle équipe les newell's tu peux nous
raconter ton but sur un coup-franc
mariano miro a passé à léo il a centré
et j'ai marqué à qui veux tu dédié ce
championnat diego à tous les gens que je
connais j'ai toujours dit que je
marquais souvent parce qu'il éloigne et
les défenseurs c'était plus facile pour
les un contre un on été très gâté parce
qu'on marquait beaucoup mais ensuite
c'est devenu plus difficile
le problème c'est que quand on gagnait 2
1 ou 3 ou 3 2 c'était trop déprimant
comment tu t'appelles guerre de grigny
donc le préféré river avec les eau ont
gagné 7 à 0 ou huit ou neuf sont les os
2 ou 3 une fois on a gagné c'est zéro tu
te souviens ont marqué tous débute un
jour on a marqué tellement buts qui nous
ont dit vous allez jouer les uns contre
les autres les newell de la première mi
temps contre les newell's de la deuxième
mi temps il était timide avec les
inconnus mais dans notre petit groupe il
était toujours génial c'était un pitre
le faisait partie de la bande ton nom et
ton prénom francou casanova
de quelle équipe à qui tu dédie ce but à
tous ceux que je connais on savait tous
que c'était notre chef naturel il
s'emparait toujours du ballon il nous
faisait gagner nos matches c'était un
chef silencieux je les gardais jusqu'à
11 ans ensuite c'est lui qui l'a pris
j'étais pas là mais voilà la machine
avec dominguez
franco mois les eaux lucas en 99 diego
je suis arrivé en survêtement rouge et
avec un sac rouge il m'a tapé dans la
main en disant c'est toi le père noël
ils cachaient les chaussures de foot me
faisait le coup tout le temps c'est
toujours lui qui était à l'origine des
farces je me suis aperçu que j'avais
oublié mes clefs de voiture où je les
avais perdu impossible de lire trouvé le
match allait commencer
je les cherche et les garçons au
vestiaire j'ai ouvert la porte et les
homes a fait
vous avez perdu vos clés c'est pas vrai
il les avait il été d'intel c'est à lui
que je me suis dit voilà un sacré
farceur vous ne laissez jamais joué
j'étais toujours mise à l'écart léo
grimper dans un évier pour attraper les
fruits ou y cueillir des mûres ils
passaient tous les étés dans les arbres
si petit si call il était très timide il
était très brave ce qui m'a toujours plu
c'est qu'il n'était jamais méchant
jamais sur noye il était timide et
réservé c'est vrai je ne crois pas qu'il
avait un problème relationnel avec ses
parents peut-être avec les adultes mais
pas avec ses parents
souvent les tournois aux frais des vélos
vainqueur souvient franco de celui du
vélo on perdait 2 à 0 et lionel n'était
toujours pas arrivé s'il jouait pour les
vélos un seul vélo non à chacun 11 lots
ouais c'est ça après le premier prix il
y avait les deuxième et troisième prix
mais nous on voulait les vélos
je vais être en retard pour les mac il
s'était enfermé dans la salle de bain et
je m'en souviens
mariano me laure brunet milanais c'est
qu'on entre koné lecointe hectares
couverts helsinn comparé à mika kallio
nous
[Applaudissements]
mais où était passée teenstar petite
ferme et là c'est la finale et on est en
train de perdre si on perd c'est votre
faute bon j'en perd 2 à 0 les eaux une
photo une photo habito applique toi
sûreté fera presse combien 20 minutes
les aux arbitres changement changement
vous allez la ferme et remis tout vient
ici
le gardien est nulle sur les tire au ras
du sol d'accord allez allez vas-y
son père l'emmenait jouer mais il ne se
mêler jamais aux autres parents c'était
quelqu'un de calme il se placer derrière
les cages pour regarder jouer son fils
mais quand il marquait pas il avait posé
la balle devant le gardien il le dribble
est quand il ne marquait pas ils devenus
fous
il a marqué à tous les matchs il voulait
tout le temps récupéré le ballon un peu
comme aujourd'hui il n'a pas changé
sinon il s'ennuie comme si on lui
enlevait son jouet de qui il était
pareil s'il n'était pas sur le terrain
il devenu fou
à 9 ans un enfant a envie de jouer sinon
il devient dingue
c'est un acteur d'une histoire qui est
la nôtre mais si aurait-il pu apparaître
en corée n'ont ni en allemagne
il paraît qu'il arrivait souvent en
retard et qu'il sauvait le match
se souvient comme on était content
léo était complètement différent sur le
terrain et hors du terrain
j'en reviens pas du troisième but il est
entré 20 minutes avant la fin et il a
retourné le match ils ont fait rentrer
et il a marqué à la chaîne une but
et c'est un champion il n'aurait pas pu
donner avait le plus grand
laisse-le tu fais toujours la même
blague
commenté sorti de la maison
san vierge qu'est ce qui s'est passé
ont gagné tellement qu'on a été invité
au pérou ce maillot c'était pendant le
perron attend de palau
c'est un tournoi auquel on a participé
au pérou quand on avait 8 ans
on logeait dans des familles à deux ou
trois garçons par famille
[Musique]
il a aussi un style rosario beaucoup de
dribbles beaucoup de petits ponts il
donne l'exemple à tous les joueurs il
tire le meilleur de chacun tu te sens en
confiance quand ils te passe le ballon
tu sens que tu dois bien faire on était
motivés
voilà l'équipe
c'était typiquement la façon de jouer de
léo
on a gagné tous nos matches et en a fini
champion ils étaient impressionnants
tout le monde devenait le voile était
exceptionnelle petit il était vraiment
très très très fragile
il était minuscule ce gamin les rendait
tout faux hors du terrain il payait pas
de mine on ne tirera rien de ce gosse on
ne sait même pas s'il va grandir est ce
qu'il va devenir il est allé consulter
un endocrinologue à rosario je l'a vu
pour la première fois à neuf en 97
comme nous l'avions évoqué la dernière
fois et comme nous le soupçonnions les
analyses confirment une déficience en
hormone de croissance qu'est ce que ça
veut dire docteur qu'elle manque à léo
une hormone dont il a besoin pour
grandir normalement il ne grandira plus
si on ne commence pas un traitement
maintenant il aura beaucoup de
difficulté à grandir normalement
d'accord mais quel traitement il s'agit
d'un gestion avec une seringue qui
ressemble un stylo c'est très facile à
utiliser c'est ce qu'utilisent les
diabétiques il s'injectait à chaque jour
une dose d'hormones mais c'est un
traitement agressif non ce sont des
injections mais l'aiguillé très fine
c'est presque sans douleur mais c'est
cher on essaiera de faire rembourser le
traitement par la sécurité sociale est
ce que je pourrais encore jouer au
football bien sûr quelle question
c'était toujours toi le plus petit sur
le terrain non soit tranquille qui va
grandir et tu seras plus grand que
maradona je ne sais pas si tu sera
meilleur mais tu seras plus grand c'est
certain quand j'allais le chercher il
disait toujours attend moins une seconde
j'arrive
à l'est tout chez moi après le foot et
il est où disparaissaient tout de suite
quand il restait dormir chez moi il
devait prendre son matériel d'injection
se piquer tout seul c'est vraiment
courageux à 10 ou 11 ans
sa mère nous avait raconté qu'il avait
appris à se piquer pour pouvoir partir
en voyage scolaire on ne faisait pas
toute une histoire avec ce traitement
tout le monde était au courant
en temps vous propose de traiter votre
enfant pour qu'il grandisse j'imagine
qu'on doit avoir des doutes il devait
être très inquiet ça fait peur c'est
risqué mais ils ont pris la décision et
ça a été une réussite toutes les mamans
du monde veulent le bien de leurs
enfants oui c'est vrai et c'est ce
qu'elle a voulu pour lionel c'est
certain
leo très bien moi quand tu fais ça c'est
bon maintenant je finis tu ne veux pas
que je t'aide non tout va bien
je vais me douche et
[Musique]
quand il revenait il disait j'ai dû me
piquer pour le traitement il utiliser
ceci c'est avec ça que messi est devenu
aussi non
certains prétendent qu'il est une star
grâce à ce traitement je le prescrire et
à mon propre fils sans hésiter s'il
n'avait pas reçu ce traitement même avec
autant de talent et ce qu'il aurait eu
les mêmes chances non je crois pas
qu'ils aient sur les dernières photos il
faisait une tête de plus que moi c'est
incroyable comme il avait grandi il
savait que c'était dans son intérêt
tous ceux qui connaissent ces impasses
savent que les voitures ne circulent pas
parce que les jeunes jouent au foot et
ses impasses joue un grand rôle dans
l'histoire de ces jeunes
cela dû jouer un rôle dans sa capacité à
gérer les situations tendues et les
conflits parce que rosario est une ville
extrême extrêmement tout
footballistiquement elle est incroyable
les autres villes ont une image
culturelle non
à rosario ce qui compte le plus c'est le
football
rosario adore le football léo a le foot
de rue dans la peau et il aura toute sa
vie voilà ce qu'il distingue exactement
c'est ça la différence
voilà la différence
quelle que soit la quantité d'hormones
qu'on donne un enfant il grandira en
fonction de ce que lui disent ces jeunes
on s'est juste contenté de guérir une
maladie
et minus tu peux pas te balader ici tout
seul qu'est ce qui se passe
est intense que je te dis
il est à toi ce vélo tu veux pas me
prêter un peu que je avec du calme
martin alors là c'est le bébé va appeler
sa maman en pleurant
plutôt pleurer que d'être une poule
mouillée comme toi
vas-y répète et en plus des sceaux
rosario le che guevara de rosario la
tête du rhin cabochard je sais quelle
heure est il aucune idée il doit jouer
dehors vraiment ce gamin je ne comprends
pas qu'il ne soit pas là qu'est ce qui
s'est passé les eaux qu'est ce qui est
arrivé c'est des grands et m'ont volé
mon vélo je n'arrive pas à le croire ils
ont cassé mes médicaments comment c'est
arrivé et se sont moqués de moi ils se
sont moqués de toi si on se moque de toi
tu baisse la tête et tu continues à
marcher
il se moquait matin
lionel grâce à ça tu vas pouvoir grandir
tu comprends tu ne peux pas perdre des
doses dès que quelqu'un se moque de toi
tu sais combien sa courte trêve à ils
t'ont fait mal est ce qu'ils t'ont
blessé non maman t'inquiète pas elles se
sont enfuies
[Musique]
le traitement a duré pendant toutes sa
phase de croissance au début du
traitement il mesurait à mettre 24 à
mettre 25 aujourd'hui le fait moins d'un
mètre soixante dix il doit pas être loin
disons 1 m 68 sûrement moins d'un mètre
soixante dix il mesure 1 mètre 69 il a
grandi de 40 cm voyons combien tu
mesures
tiens toi bien droit ne triche pas
dix ans
c'est formidable que tu as encore un peu
grandi oui pour devenir joueur de foot
c'est bien tu as joué dimanche oui on a
gagné tu vas marquer des buts oui
combien 3 alors tu veux donc devenir
footballeur comme qui comme tata comme
tata et marc tu vas jouer avec nous oui
tu marqueras pour moi oui je vous le
dédicacerai génial tu m'en doit aller
fils l'état des biens but non mais une
mendois je veux qu'il le marque sur la
pelouse de newell sur la pelouse de
niort est pour l'instant qu'ils se
fassent plaisir on verra ça plus tard
j'habitais à 3 rue de la pension il
venait chez moi à boire du lait l'huile
et au look as cagliari et on jouer à la
playstation léo n'était pas très bon à
la playstation ont
aujourd'hui il dit cui savait pas
comment il était pas bon à la paix s à
l'époque il était carrément mauvais non
non je me souviens qu'on jouer à fifa 94
et 95 sur la family non sur la saga il
l'était n'y es tu t'en souviens quand
ils perdaient ils allaient l'éteindre il
était mauvais perdant il l'était niais
il était mauvais perdants à la
playstation et à la sega c'était pareil
chez luca
tu fais quoi luca les grands néo vous
sentez pas ils sont sortis renseigne
coupe du monde une coupe du monde on
joue chacun pour soi allez si vous
voulez perdre on met les maillots non ma
mère sera furieuse pourquoi parce que
vous les salissent est allé s'te plaît
c'est pas pareil sont les maillots
je veux celui de madrid c'est moi qui
prends madrid
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
leo leoni c'est le seul qui l'a jamais
porté il enlevait seulement en partant
il était dingue de barcelone il les
adorait à l'époque il y avait plus verte
et rivaldo rivaldo et frank de boer il
est tout seul aulas pro la france allez
va sur le ballon vas-y fais voir dieu
l'attaquent puisse éclater ippon but
aller à ne plus salut salut ça va c'est
antonella ma cousine qui habite au
dessus vous voulez manger on attend une
pizza
but mais quel but idiot
c'est peut-être faisait leo quand il a
vu antonella à une tête d'amoureux
qui est tombé amoureux c'est lui en
premier il a eu du mal il a ramé à il a
ramé il a rencontré quand il avait 11
ans il la connaissait déjà il a fini par
épouser sa petite amie de rosario ça en
dit long sur sa personnalité
c'est clair alors qu'on pourrait le voir
dans les pages people des magazines du
monde entier mais il revient aux
nouvelles ce parce que c'est un gars
loyal regardez c'est notre voyage
scolaire de sixième on a le dvd de notre
voyage scolaire
ça va être génial
voilà meilleur buteur on est les
meilleurs la gagner
là c'est moi
voilà walter
voilà les eaux et la cdo
cynthia on est et où là c'est moi qui
passe là
je me rappelle de la tête de walter
quand il conduisait
me cogner partout il allait à fond
accident c'est à fond accident il
connaissait que le tricycle
ils ont fait reportage sur lui à 12 ans
quand je m'entraînais comment tu
t'appelles lionel messi c'est toi le
meilleur joueur du match tu savais ça
non il raconte son but la deuxième but
le deuxième raconte moi
federico ressentir et righini la passât
loucas louca me la passe en retrait et
je marque
tu as marqué deux buts c'est ça à qui
dit tu ce championnat à mon père à mon
oncle a toute ma famille à tous mes amis
à toute sa famille à toute sa famille
connaissant son père je ne crois pas
qu'on lui ai jamais dit tu dois faire si
tu dois faire ça non c'est naturel rob
est comme ça
en octobre 99 est venu près de la
clôture du terrain numéro 2 où on
s'entraînait
quand je lui dis bonjour il m'a dit
profitez-en bien des deux prochains mois
ouais je me souviens je lui ai demandé
pourquoi il m'a dit profitez-en parce
que je l'emmène ailleurs je les
regardais je lui ai dit où est ce que
vous l'emmenez léo était imbattable
surtout ne venez pas à centrale
heureusement il est parti pourquoi il
est parti je me souviens plus si c'était
un problème de sécurité sociale ou un
problème d'emploi il faudrait appeler
mais si pour lui demander ce qui s'est
vraiment passé
mon père allait se retrouver sans
travail et on allait avoir des
difficultés il ne pouvait plus payer les
médicaments ce qui était crucial sinon
il serait resté petit pour toujours deux
clubs n'ont pas pu financer le
traitement newell's et river ils ont
aussi essayé avec river il me semble ils
ont essayé avec river oui à buenos aires
la famille a dit que newell ne prenait
pas en charge le traitement
lopez a dû s'ouvrir les veines nom que
rivers ne pouvait en payer que la moitié
exact il était tellement petit que les
dirigeants du penser qu'il n'avait aucun
avenir en argentine la situation
politico-économique c'était ce tel
foutoir la dévaluation la pacification
sécurité sociale avait des problèmes
pour lui fournir régulièrement son
traitement le père de léo était allé
frapper aux portes pour que les clubs
argentins finance son traitement
progresser senti désemparé il a voulu
emmener les eaux pour montrer sa colère
dans ce club on avait un champion avec
un avenir très prometteur et il ne
pouvait pas l'aider les seuls qui ont
pris le risque de l'aider c'est
barcelone
célia nous en a parlé à l'école elle a
dit ses parents ne peuvent plus payer le
traitement et le club non plus
c'était très cher alors quand le
représentant du barça est arrivé
le père a dit il a décidé c'est bon on y
va si les eaux étaient restées en
argentine
je ne sais pas s'il serait devenu ce
qu'il est non ils sont partis seuls les
eaux et son papa il était si petit la
famille est restée il est parti à 13 ans
je me souviens encore du jour où il est
parti je suis allé lui dire au revoir
j'étais en retard le jour où il est
parti ils nous ont coupé l'électricité
pendant trois jours non la panne a duré
cinq jours en tout cas c'était très
émouvant parce qu'il avait un lien très
fort avec ceux de son quartier
c'était horrible je me souviens que tout
le monde pleurait lui aussi il pleurait
évidemment je suis très triste
mais joyeux en même temps à cause de
l'endroit où je vais jouer
[Musique]
ça ne te plaît pas les eaux
à les souris
[Musique]
léo souris
allez
on va aller se promener paint toi fais
le pour ta mère allez s'il te plaît oui
c'est ça paye toi comme ça or tu es
tellement lent tu comptes jouait aussi
lentement dit moi
[Musique]
quand tu étais annuel c'était avec tes
amis tu t'es senti nerveux ici comment
tu as vécu des premiers entraînements
les premiers jours j'étais un peu
nerveux mais ensuite je me suis adapté
quand il est arrivé en même temps que
moi à 13 ans au centre de la masia il
était très mal à l'aise les premiers
jours dans le vestiaire les eaux s'est
assis à l'écart de tous les autres
[Musique]
il
ça va tu as parlé avec quelqu'un non
juste un petit peu avec un garçon qu'est
ce qu'il fait là le petit je pense que
c'est un fugueur
et non c'est demain les essais pour les
ramasseurs de balle ils s'asseyaient
dans un coin et il observait les autres
un petit coin un petit coin nous envoyer
tous à la périphérie ensuite il s'est
senti plus à l'aise qu'est ce que tu
fais à l'entraînement
je travaille avec le ballon je tire des
buts je travaille avec les cônes ont
fait d un contrat et après on fait un
match
[Musique]
m
comment tu t'appelles mais si mais si il
était très fragile ce n'était qu'un
enfant il était incroyablement petit
aussi incroyablement bon je me souviens
d'une anecdote l'entraîneur nous avait
dit ménager le il est fragile vous allez
le tuer il était intouchable on
répondrait pas de souci mais c'est parce
qu'on n'arrivait pas à le rattraper la
première fois que j'ai vu les eaux il
avait 13 ans et je me suis demandé s'il
était capable de devenir professionnel
c'est toujours la grande inconnue des
gamins super doué qui dribble six
adversaires et mettre un but j'en ai vu
beaucoup
j'ai vu disparaître une quantité de
grands joueurs
c'est bien continue vas-y fais des têtes
allaient
à l'eau ce garçon me plaît beaucoup il
est incroyable
alors j'en ai parlé avec les dirigeants
génial on va fêter ça ouais ce gamin est
un champion croyez moi c'est un champion
aujourd'hui mais quand les autres ne
dépasserons alors financer son
traitement tu sais combien ça coûte et
si on paye qu'il n'y a pas de résultats
vous devez le voir c'est vraiment le
meilleur que j'aie jamais vue sur le
laisse passer on le regrettera toute
notre vie certains se posaient à cette
idée alors que d'autres étaient
impressionnés on est un club de foot
planes et on ne voit pas ça à son âge
normalement ça vient à 17 ou 18 ans dans
quelques années ce sera trop tard ce
gamin finira dans un des cinq meilleurs
clubs européens qu'est ce que tu as fait
à barcelone les premiers jours on a
visité tout barcelone
chaque voulait voir ses essais mairie
chaque était absent il était en
déplacement
ils devaient revenir des jeux olympiques
c'était difficile pour ce garçon de
devoir attendre une réponse ils ont
attendu dans un hôtel que le barça les
appels mais il n'a prépa ils passaient
tout leur journée dans l'hôtel a regardé
par la fenêtre ça fait deux semaines
qu'on attend c'est un peu long non c'est
difficile pour le club de prendre un tel
risque d'accord mais qu'est ce qu'ils
veulent de plus j'ai quitté mon travail
à rosario pour venir ici mon fils est
séparé de sa famille il ya beaucoup de
problèmes le contrat est compliqué ça
prend du temps et le traitement est plus
cher que prévu
il faut loger toute votre famille
puisque c'est si compliqué alors on s'en
va ciao
écoutez c'est bon si ça ne tenait qu'à
moi je signerai demain je vais parler au
vice-président vous aurez la réponse
dans quelques jours les jeux olympiques
ont tout retardé mais il a continué à
jouer qu'est ce que tu as le plus admiré
le stade de barcelone
pour son père c'était peut-être plus
difficile les eaux je n'ai jamais
remarqué qu'ils ont souffrait le seul
match pour lequel les eaux a retenu
qu'il était nerveux c'est un match test
avec des garçons plus âgés de 2 ans
ray chaque la vue c'est un ancien joueur
de barcelone il était directeur sportif
exact
que fait ce gamin ici
lequel lui il devrait pas joué en
juniors
c'est le fameux gamin il vient juste
d'avoir 13 ans mais il a une déficience
en hormone de croissance on doit
financer son traitement mais rien ne
garantit le résultat bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vas-y vas-y la défense
à peine le club dealer qu'il nous faut
ce gamin à n'importe quel prix foued
dingue pour voir messi pendant l'un
tests et ne pas comprendre qu'il est
génial j'ai fait signer un contrat à léo
il a fallu remplir la case observation
j'ai indiqué petit maradona parce qu'ils
étaient comme lui pour cocher la tête
basse a droit au but la verticalité la
vitesse la rapidité d'exécution il avait
tout ça c'était un petit maradona je
n'avais aucun doute là dessus
le mois de barcelone d'abord quand as tu
découvert que tu avais une chance et
ensuite comment se passent les
entraînements au club
c'était génial d'être là de jouer à
barcelone le plus grand club du monde
c'était fantastique
et où est arrivé le premier
ensuite mathias est venu oui les uns
après les autres je me souviens que
quand mathias est parti le grand père
nous a emmenés dans son pick-up matthias
a crié au grand-père arrête arrête
il est descendu pour embrasser l'angle
de la rue dit ciao et il est parti ce
quartier avait quelque chose de spécial
on s'en va mais on revient toujours on
est tous restés les spéciales
pendant un moment on s'est retrouvé dans
une situation comment dire anormal il
était à barcelone sa famille était
installée ici mais les papiers
n'arrivait pas les eaux et forêts
étaient les seuls à avoir un permis de
séjour
m'a dit que sa famille avait vécu des
moments difficiles
il trouvait aussi la langue pas simple
il lui apprenait le catalan bon
je m'appelle narnia et j'ai de bons et
je viens d'argentine bien en catalan
elle met ou non
des maliens
techno
elle sort je ne sais pas et je m'en
fiche oui je sais mais la fifa que dit
la fifa
j'en sais rien insisté la solution ne va
pas arriver tout seul discuter mais
taylor la pression
d'accord d'accord d'accord
on en reparlera demain
n'ont toujours pas parlé en ouest tu
crois on est là depuis quatre mois et
léo n'a toujours aucun contrat tu
réalises que c'est que de s'entraîner
tous les jours sans pouvoir participer
au championnat vient
montrer crois vraiment que ça a un sens
de rester ici
commence à un sens tu vois dans quel
état on est on est tous perdu
loin de la famille de la maison de nos
amis marianne n'arrive pas à prendre le
catalan elle va perdre un an d'école
mathias ne va pas bien sa fiancée lui
manque
c'est pas possible je sais que c'est un
milieu difficile que c'est dur de
négocier et même si léo est doué
il y a beaucoup trop de choses qui nous
échappe ici
pourquoi tu ne restes pas avec lui
tu m'entends
ans au garçon ce sont ses frères
et laisse-moi par les allées on est tous
d'accord
je vais voir ce qu'il en dit
athée là
j'étais en train de parler avec ta mère
j'ai envie de jouer à barcelone
très bien
je resterai ici avec toi
je suis content d'être revenu je dois
encore tenir le rythme son objectif
c'était de jouer à barcelone et il a
tout misé là dessus il était gonflé je
vais réussir à barcelone je reste célia
sa mère est rentrée et rhorer rester
avec les salles a anéanti mais il avait
la conviction qu'ils réussiraient ils te
regardait il disait je vais devenir le
meilleur sur demande à léo qu'elle a été
le pire moment de toute cette histoire
incroyable qu'il a vécu c'est celui ci
c'est sûr c'était ni les injections ni
quand la sélection la critiquer ni
camper kerman ne l'a pas sélectionné
contre l'allemagne dira que le pire
moment a été la séparation d'avec sa
famille il s'est senti un peu
responsable du fait que re aurait été
ici et célia là bas personne ne pouvait
lui assurer que ça marcherait au bout
d'un an ils te disent retourne chez toi
je crois que sa mère faisait des allers
retours depuis l'argentine mais son père
est toujours resté ici à barcelone
j'ai vécu la même expérience je suis
parti en angleterre à 17 ans et je me
suis sentie complètement seul et malgré
mes 17 ans j'ai aussi beaucoup souffert
mais bon quand on voit le résultat on a
bien fait de venir
ils n'habitaient pas au centre de la
masia mais avec son père dans un très
grand appartement il a fallu une année
pour que son père sache s'il était pris
ou pas pourquoi la procédure pour
établir les papiers a été assez
laborieuses
on sera tous rentrés au pays au bout de
six mois parce que l'autorisation de
transfert de new west n'arrivait pas
ensuite il ya eu la blessure au péroné
la blessure à la cheville en descendant
les escaliers chez lui
venant d'argentine il était assis dans
l'avion à l'aéroport d'ezeiza il a
commencé à pleurer à côté trop
réponse est vu une seconde fois et on a
préparé un contrat qui prévoyait déjà
une carrière de cet habitant j'ai pensé
on signe pour des centaines de milliers
de pc tu as c'était encore les pc tu as
c'est délirant pour un garçon de 13 ans
il a un problème sa famille est rentré
en argentine
les autres dirigeants m'ont dit c'est de
la folie on devait vraiment être un peu
fou autrement on n'aurait jamais donné
notre aval à un tel projet il était
tellement petit qu'il l'ont descendu
d'une catégorie il était en juniors à
avec nous ils ont mis en juniors d quand
il a débuté au barça avec les juniors un
jour le barça a gagné 14 ans il a
marquer trois ou quatre buts il a dit
ils m'ont attendu tellement longtemps je
suis là depuis un an je vais leur
montrer au cours du deuxième match
officiel il s'est blessé il s'est cassé
la jambe pendant un match il a pris un
coup
il est reparti en ambulance
quand on allait au cybercafé l'internet
se couper la conversation s'arrêter en
plein milieu c'était dur d'être aussi
éloignées j'ai perdu le contact il a
tout laissé derrière lui pour
recommencer la ba oui il était en pleine
adolescence c'était difficile de quitter
ses amis
il a commencé le traitement à 9 ans et
il l'a terminée en espagne de temps en
temps il ne s'entraînait pas parce
qu'ils avaient reçu son injection le
médecin venait nous dire les eaux ne
s'entraînera pas il a eu une injection
hier
[Musique]
il a connu une progression sportive
fulgurante je manque d'endurance et de
vitesse
je suis vite fatigué
arriver à dépasser les cadets espagnol
as c'est mon grand rêve
c'est super j'ai marqué cinq buts
j'espère marquer d'autres au début entre
la blessure et le reste c'était
difficile mais maintenant je me sens
bien quand il est rentré d'espagne et où
était beaucoup plus musclé beaucoup plus
grand un impact contre lui c'est comme
avec quelqu'un d'un mètre 85 on ne peut
plus le faire bouger une force physique
incroyable on voyait tous ses muscles du
muscle de la fibre on a vu les progrès
en puissance en vitesse en rythme
personne n'est aussi explosif que lui il
a développé ses qualités physiques avec
du temps et du travail il a travaillé un
peu sa force ses quadriceps pour
l'explosivité
super viril ah oui je lui ai dit c'est
dingue comme tu es viril il était devenu
un homme
un jour on le voyant jouer dans le
centre je les prie pour un cas d'e on
lui en fracturé la pommette d'un coup de
coude il s'est mis à pleurer pas à cause
de sa pommette brisé mais parce qu'il
pensait raté la finale du championnat de
catalogne et finalement il a joué avec
le masque de puyol et lui avait dit si
le masque de jeunes on ne sort mais oui
bien sûr il a commencé à jouer il
transpirait le masque bouger le masque
de puyol qui l'avaient emprunté il a
enlevé son masque et il a joué sans son
père aurait a failli en faire une
attaque il a gagné le match et il est
parti mais si tout d'abord
c'est un diamant d'un des plus beaux
il a ensuite trouvé des gens qu'ils ont
taillé pour qu'il brille il n'a pas été
ternie par des idiots
certains joueurs sont ternies par des
dirigeants stupide
ça en dit long sur ceux qui l'ont dirigé
on est devant la vision de quelqu'un
capable de dire on va en discuter même
si c'est contraire aux habitudes
c'est ce qui s'est passé avait créé
chaque épreuve qui ont su dépasser les
blocages et crée la pierre philosophale
jouer le ballon et contrôler le terrain
attaquer quand on peut ralentir quand il
faut récupérer toutes ces choses là ça a
commencé avec réf léo a profité au barça
de condition qu'ils n'auraient jamais eu
dans la majorité des autres clubs du
monde même en étant le meilleur joueur
du monde aucun doute là dessus allez
premier entraînement de l'année je veux
vous voir sur les ballons vous êtes
reposé vous rentrez de vacances
maintenant il faut vous mettre les piles
et retrouver rapidement la forme allez
allez allez allez allez vous êtes monté
d'une catégorie vous allez en baver
arrêté d'applaudir aller au boulot
léo jouer dans l'équipe b du barça et
frank rijkaard m'a demandé s'il pouvait
emprunter quelques joueurs pour un match
amical à assen tasse contre porto
il était très respectueux il m'a dit
c'est toi qui décide j'ai répondu il y à
cela et il ya messi il m'a regardé il
m'a demandé qui s'aimait si
salut salut
c'est lui c'est sa ricarde était un
entraîneur qui faisait confiance aux
jeunes ils les incorporer dans son
équipe il prenait messi iniesta et les
autres et il l'a choisi c'est peut être
quelque chose quand on a 16 ans de jouer
pour barcelone non adias ja voir c'est
léo scellés ou tais toi un peu je
commence mercredi dans l'équipe première
maman qu'est ce qu'il dit il dit qu'il
va débuter dans l'équipe première
comment ça a débuté allez raconte idiot
parce que moi passent le mois bien sûr
qu'on va venir tu fais quand même tes
débuts on a tout acheté pour partir t'en
fais pas on va venir ça 30 il
quand j'ai vu débuter je crois que
c'était contre porto au match avec le
maillot gris c'est ça avec le maillot
gris le maillot brun oui le brun avec le
numéro 14 ma mère m'a crié diego léo va
rentrer j'ai fait tous les papiers
aujourd'hui j'espère que je pourrai être
sélectionnés et j'en ai très envie est
ce une légende ou la réalité est vivace
l'a empêché de signer pour l'espagne
est-ce que grande donadi fait le jouet
dans un match sinon il jouera sous un
autre maillot je vais te raconter
c'était la demi finale contre l'espagne
je te parle de 2003 ont rentré à l'hôtel
ont partagé le même hôtel que les
espagnols l'espagne a toujours eu un
chef cuisinier je marchais quand il est
venu me saluer il m'a dit monsieur toc
ali non je suis occupé excusez moi je
voudrais vous parler d'un jeune leo
messi de rosario vous connaissez je ne
parle pas à faire avec des inconnus
contacté la fédération il a 15 ans les
espagnols veulent le sélectionner mais
il veut jouer dans la sélection
argentine le gamin de 15 ans ne voudrait
pas jouer dans la sélection argentine je
ne comprenais pas c'est un phénomène un
génie si vous ne le prenez pas dans les
moins de 17 ans on ne perdra pour
toujours si on m'avait payé à chaque
fois que j'ai entendu ça je serai
multimillionnaire pardon attendait son
père vous envoie ça si ça ne vous
intéresse pas tant pis mais sinon appelé
le 7 urgent je vous en prie il pose
surtout n'en parlez pas aux espagnols
pognon bien c'est tout oui monsieur toc
ali merci beaucoup au revoir je suis
reparti sans même le remercier alors
pour la finale des moins de 17 ans et
cuisiniers venus dire j'ai un joueur qui
va te sauver un joueur qui va me sauver
j'ai répondu non non non c'est la
sélection nationale ont fait jouer
uniquement ceux qui se sont entraînés si
ça leur plaît pas ils n'ont qu'à rentrer
chez eux tu comprends bien sûr je te les
10 ce matin tu ne m'écoutes pas au bout
du compte je suis tout seul ils nous
roulent dans la farine tu comprends ce
que je te dis ils nous roulent dans la
farine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y avait cinq actions de léo il
prenait le ballon il marchait et il
passer de 0 à 100 en 3 m
j'étais sidéré
avec josé on se disait que dans la
sélection des jeunes on avait besoin
d'un joueur rapide un joueur capable de
changer de rythme jeudi il est parfait
tu ne savait rien de lui à ce moment là
je ne connaissais pas du tout
attend une seconde s'il te plaît
[Musique]
j'ai appelé immédiatement omar soto le
responsable administratif
écoute bien ce que je vais dire écoute
moi bien
tu dois me retrouver un gamin qui habite
barcelone et qui s'appelle lionel messi
tu as compris
lionel messi je lui ai demandé de le
contacter en espagne par l'intermédiaire
de javier qui était dans l'équipe
première et qui pouvait le faire
merci
je crois qu'il a fallu 40 minutes
j'appelle de la part de la sélection
argentine de football
c'est formidable
le père du garçon était enthousiaste il
m'a dit qu'il demanderait l'autorisation
de barcelone et qu'il deviendrait il
avait 16 ans et ils ont pris dans les
moins de 20 ans ou les moins de 18 10
ans jouer contre le paraguay en match
amical c'est ce qui a permis à léo
d'entrer dans la sélection argentine
il l'a sélectionné pour l'argentine si
messi avait joué pour l'équipe d'espagne
qu'on a vu au dernier mondial et qui a
gagné deux coupes d'europe elle aurait
été imbattable
portant donc un toast à cette vidéo à ce
match que tu as organisée en argentine
et au fait que julio t autorisés à
acheter son billet pour le faire venir
au real madrid aurait fait jouer messi à
17 heures j'espère que je pourrai
continuer à jouer dans l'équipe première
il a fini par jouer dans l'équipe
première et on ne l'a pas beaucoup vu
c'était le bon moment techniquement pour
l'équipe première pour son entraîneur
d'alors et pour son effectif de joueurs
ronaldinho l'a traité comme un fils ce
sont les joueurs qui demandait fait
rentrer les eaux
[Musique]
c'est jamais facile à 16 ans de rentrer
dans le vestiaire surtout pour quelqu'un
comme moi mais ronaldinho les brésiliens
déco sylvinho motta et m'ont tout de
suite adopté le premier jour où
ronaldinho m'a fait asseoir près de lui
c'était plus facile ses coéquipiers à
barcelone ont accepté les eaux comme il
était ils ont été géniaux ils
ont tous pris sous leur aile
un match très compliqué on a pu ouvrir
le score
ça a bien marché ils l'ont protégé ils
l'ont aidé à grandir la green card était
patient très patient
rails car d'avancer étape par étape sans
se presser souvent je ne comprenais pas
pourquoi on ne me faisait pas jouer il
l'a beaucoup protégé d'autres
entraîneurs n'aurait pas pris de risque
avec lui
avec le recul je vois qu'il avait raison
je lui en suis reconnaissant parce
qu'ils savaient ce qui était le mieux
pour moi on se précipite on peut les
perdre et les dégâts sont irréparables
barcelone messi a eu à l'époque un
entraîneur qui selon moi appartient à
l'école hollandaise
tout ce que faisait rae cards étaient
simples efficaces il l'a pris dans
l'équipe première même après ses débuts
à barcelone personne ne se doutait qu'il
allait devenir le meilleur joueur du
monde le premier but qu'il a marqué à
barcelone ce jour là il a marqué un but
incroyable sur une passe de ronaldinho
un sombrero sous la transversale le
premier à venir l'embrasser a été
ronaldinho j'ai pas réalisé ce qu'il
faisait avec les cris du public j'étais
tellement content d'avoir marqué mon
premier but
ensuite quand j'y repense et au calme sa
manière de fêter ça j'ai compris que je
comptais pour lui comme si c'était lui
qui avait marqué il l'embrassé comme le
ferait un père il avait un feeling
particulier sur le terrain en plus ils
s'amusaient
incroyable
ronaldinho est quelqu'un de loyal
contrairement à certains qui se diraient
au messie progresse beaucoup
dans le vestiaire il trouver une
nouvelle idée il s'entraînait jusqu'à ce
qu'il la maîtrise et le lendemain il
nous montrait ce qu'ils avaient appris
comme arias a dit un jour ronaldinho est
un joueur de plage et messi un joueur de
rue pour messi chaque match est un match
de rue il joue même les matchs les plus
simples comme si son honneur était en
jeu c'est incroyable il joue encore pour
gagner un vélo
ronaldinho est le meilleur joueur du
monde être son remplaçant est très
impressionnant de coire est venu déjouer
dans la sélection argentine les débuts
de messi dans la sélection argentine
n'ont pas été faciles le premier match
de la coupe du monde en allemagne
contre la hongrie il était sélectionné
oui dans l'équipe première dans l'équipe
nationale il reçoit le ballon à un
défenseur la trappe par le maillot il le
fera pour se dégager et l'arbitré lui
colle un carton rouge pour comportement
violent
de la folie une folie de larbitre oui
une folie de larbi adacore léo a été
expulsé au bout de 30 secondes sur le
terrain il a pleuré dans le vestiaire
c'était dur pour lui quel dommage on
attendait beaucoup de lui dans ce match
quand as tu compris que c'était un
joueur à part un de ces joueurs qui
marquent leur époque
avec le match contre la juventus tout le
monde a commencé à ouvrir les yeux
là il s'est fait un nom on a parlé
beaucoup plus de lui
[Musique]
ce qu'il a fait au camp nou c'était
impressionnant il devait y avoir 17 ans
ce qu'il a fait ce soir
c'est impressionnant
il a montré tout son talent contre une
juventus qui a tout fait pour gagner
ils ont fait beaucoup de foot pour
tenter de l'arrêter et d'arrêter iniesta
qu'il l'à beaucoup aidé
il a donné du fil à retordre à la juve
qui avait pourtant des joueurs de haut
niveau même capello leur entraîneur a
dit je crois que je n'ai jamais vu un
joueur avec autant de qualité à cet
âge-là de la personnalité de la vitesse
il a tout regardé capello ont eu une
discussion sur la pelouse capello a dit
et tu me donnes brickyard a répondu non
pas question il faut protéger un talent
comme celui ci
ce soir il était fantastique c'était un
plaisir pour le public de le voir jouer
personne ne l'avait jamais vu avant
qu'il apparaisse au contenu c'était la
première fois qu'il criait mais si mais
si mais si
[Applaudissements]
à ce moment là tout le monde voulait
renouveler son contrat c'est alors
qu'ils ont réalisé que ce contrat était
précaire le contrat de messi il est
toujours précaire il est précaire tous
les jours il a été renouvelé 6 fois ci
renouvellement sa première sortie
internationale c'était contre chelsea du
délire je crois que del horno a dû faire
des cauchemars de messine semaine
entière et le cinéma noir et niort du
cinéma
du très bon cinéma
le match contre chelsea à stamford
bridge a marqué sa carrière
lors nous l'a puni bien au delà de ce
qu'un joueur peut supporter c'est la
première fois que j'ai vu mais si dans
un match d'une telle intensité
ce match m'a appris beaucoup sur messi
et surtout sur la terreur qu'il
inspirait à ses rivaux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on avait regardé real madrid barcelone
ensemble dans un bar il avait fait quoi
un triplé sa date oui un triplé il a
marqué les trois buts du clasico énorme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'était énorme ensuite est arrivé selon
moi est de loin le meilleur entraîneur
du monde de loi guardiola a trouvé une
équipe où jouer messi eto'o ronaldinho
et henry excusez du peu il avait du pain
sur la planche et ils ont agi très
rapidement
adieu ronaldinho et ronaldinho s'en va
il donne le 10ème ici et on commence à
se demander si laporta a dit ronaldinho
on va s'arrêter là ils ont pleuré tous
les deux ils se sont embrassés il
apporta est sorti j'ai téléphoné à henry
messi et il a dit leo c'est toi le
patron il avait 21 ans j'imagine qu'ils
aient réagi en disant vous virer mes
amis mon frère adoptif mais très vite il
est de dire on aura quelle équipe quelle
formation quels joueurs viendront je
crois qu'à ce moment là le patron
n'était pas mais si je crois qu'à 21 ans
messi n'était pas le patron du barça
c'est ce qui lui ont vendu le patron de
barcelone c'était guardiola le leader
qui a décidé de placer messi au centre
de la scène c'est guardiola il a fait un
jour très précis quand le barça a battu
le real 6 2 et qui l'a pratiquement
virait eto'o de l'effectif il l'a placé
en périphérie à l' aile droite et il a
mimé si dans laxe comme info avant
centre c'était une décision symbolique
qui signifiait cette équipe va
s'organiser autour de toi parce que
cette équipe n'avait pas encore été
construites mais ça n'a pas été une
décision de messi c'était une décision
de guardiola messi a grandi entre autres
raisons parce que guardiola avait deviné
kétou était un leader tribal qui au lieu
d'aider mais si le surprotéger et qu'il
valait mieux pour messi kétou ne soit
plus là ronaldinho est parti parce qu'il
croyait que son pouvoir d'absorption
affaibli c'est le rôle de leader de
messi il s'est alors retrouvé dans la
situation de devoir assumer son rôle et
c'est guardiola qui a créé
quand vous ouvrez la porte et que vous
dites bonjour ils savent tous ce qui
vous êtes c'est clair quand guardiola
ouvre la porte d'un vestiaire tout le
monde sait comment il faut jouer
l'entraîneur fait tout pour ça et
barcelone a commencé à progresser avec
lui comme leader
une génération à son service personne
n'a discuté et ceux qui doutaient de
messi ont fini comme cadavres au barça
que se serait-il passé si cristiano
ronaldo avait joué à barcelone et messi
pour mourinho bonne question
on l'aurait vu la même chose ou bien
ronaldo aurait t'il quitter barcelone
comme beaucoup de grands joueurs
léo adore jouer au foot de rue avec ses
potes il aime jouer avec ceux qui ont la
même idée du foot que lui il a surtout
besoin d'être entouré de complices si je
puis dire de copains c'est ça finalement
ils sont en quelque sorte connectés je
te la passe tu me la passe je me
souviens quand zlatan est venu ici un an
c'était un joueur beaucoup plus
anarchique c'était aussi un super joueur
mais il avait du mal à se connecter avec
lui mais si doit-il jouer avec les
meilleurs ou avec ceux qui le
comprennent le mieux avec ceux qui le
comprennent le mieux ceux qui le
comprennent ça peut être les meilleurs
certains attaquants ont dû partir parce
que ça fonctionnait pas avec léo il ya
eto'o brian kerr kitsch ibrahimovic
on joue de cette façon à barcelone si
vous voulez jouer autrement changer
d'équipé ibra était un obstacle un
défenseur de plus une barrière messi a
besoin de perspectives quand messi a le
ballon tu le dis je dois l'aider il faut
dégager les adversaires et le laisser
jouer les uns contre uns ça veut dire
quoi est d offrir à son coéquipier les
meilleures conditions c'est ça et dès la
première chose qu'il faut définir à mon
avis c'est pourquoi est-ce un joueur
hors norme oui le football n'est pas
quelque chose de très mystérieux pas une
histoire de 4 3 4 ou autres numéros de
téléphone dans le football il y a quatre
actions définir concevoir récupérer et
défendre quatre actions messi était
d'abord un formidable des finisseurs
d'abord comme ailier sur un côté mais
ensuite on a découvert une nouvelle
position le faux numéro 9 info 9 il a
trouvé un poste où il exploite au mieux
ses qualités c'est certain et tout le
mérite revient à guardiola dehors
ils jouent dedans peu importe qu'il joue
comme un dieu il ne manquerait plus
qu'ils défendent bien et le sprint de
l'autre jour contre connu
son père aurait messi m'a parlé du jour
où il a découvert que son fils était un
phénomène il m'a dit qu'ils avaient fait
un cercle avec messi au centre il se
passait le ballon et dès qu'il est
rentré il s'est jeté dans les jambes de
celui qui avait le ballon et la
récupérer il voulait absolument la balle
messi a besoin du ballon ça c'est vrai
c'est comme si un violoniste ne pouvait
avoir son violon que toutes les deux
minutes
à toi de jouer maintenant comme si le
rck est rejoué pendant une heure et que
le soliste le virtuose ne jouer que deux
notes
messi n'a pas le ballon
c'est un joueur ordinaire que vous
donniez un messie 30 ballons ou 5
j'ai vu un match en argentine où messi
n'a touché que quatre valeurs il faudra
un miracle pour marquer quatre fois avec
quatre possessions de balle impossible
on voudrait que messi est toujours le
ballon parce qu'on sait qu'au minimum il
le passera toujours à quelqu'un qui
porte le même maillot et là
on respire vous savez ce que c'est qu'un
jour on s'était réunis j'ai fait sortir
maradona et j'ai demandé à tout le monde
combien de ballons vous allez donner à
maradona
là ils m'ont regardé et j'ai dit tous
voilà pourquoi pour son jeu un boosket
un xavi et iniesta sont essentiels pour
qu'il puisse jouer
d'autant plus que quand ils peuvent se
voir le regard sont à la même hauteur
car ils font la même taille le même
poids non la taille c'est très important
tu vois tout
vous n'avez pas idée de l'importance
pour la carrière d'un joueur de pouvoir
compter sur trois ou quatre joueurs sur
le terrain on pourrait se distribuer des
médailles et dire que c'est vrai mais
les eaux et les eaux peu importe avec
qui il joue j'ai entendu cruijff dire un
jour qu'à l'origine de tout ça il y
avait xavi il maintient toujours un
certain rythme
xavi a le ballon et il fait une passe
rapide à messi quand il est libre et
qu'il peut démarrer c'est pas je passe
le ballon on verra bien maintenant il ya
aussi iniesta et lui c'est une autre
histoire
tu t'entends très bien avec lui quand tu
lui fais la dernière passe et qu'il
s'arrête tu sais que quand tu la passe
il te la renverra la perfection un une
deux parfait sur deux ont de bons
joueurs avec le même profil ils sont
connectés connectés oui je réussirai
jamais à faire un une deux avec lui
jamais
ça
ma cabane et jls a été nommé vitrées des
points finaux madina qui s'abattent
avant et spectacles où la province
chisinau révèle alors finale et la ligue
avec un piolet
vous savez la fragilité au travers
les gens croient souvent que le football
se joue surtout avec les pieds je dis
qu'on joue avec sa tête et qu'on utilise
ses pieds ce qui me plaît c'est qu'on
peut toujours transformer un défaut en
avantage un petit joueur ne rivalise pas
avec un grand sa zone de contrôle est
inférieure
il ne peut pas attaquer frontalement il
est plus bas quand il pousse il pousse
ici à une époque barcelone avait
beaucoup de petits joueurs et presque
tous posséder cette qualité il profitait
des chocs car quand on te pousse tu
récupères de la vitesse quand on dit les
petits ne font pas de tête j'aimerais
faire les mêmes que lui il a un marteau
dans la tête
il ya une photo de la finale c'était la
chaume jocelyne non quel but une auteure
incroyable
[Musique]
ce un bon stupéfiants
j'ai entendu que piquet à l'entraînement
j'ai souvent vécu ça à l'entraînement
quand je devais le marquer en défense
ils te donnent l'impression que tu sais
de quel côté il partira qu'il fera ceci
tu sais ce qu'il fera qu'il partira par
là je sais par où il sortira mais même
en le sachant tu peut pas l'arrêter et
il sort et il parle exacte et il part
ouais on a l'impression que s'il a envie
de passer il le fait et s'il n'en a pas
envie il ne le fait pas il joue avec toi
on savait quand ils allaient toucher le
ballon on croit avoir deux contacts mais
il y en a qu'un seul il peut le toucher
ou pas
qu'ils ne touchent ou pas c'est pareil
mais si tu fais un pas en arrière il
recule toujours quand j'entends les gens
chanter les louanges de messi évidemment
regarder ça c'est bien plus important
bien mieux que de marquer un but
beaucoup de joueurs sont capables de
marquer deux beaux buts
le cir messi récupère le ballon il
n'hésite jamais
[Applaudissements]
de quoi il avait l'air
d'un monstre j'avais rarement vu un
joueur courir aussi rapidement avec la
balle au pied très rarement son gros
avantage quand il court avec le ballon
c'est qu'il fait deux foules et quand
les défenseurs n'en font qu'une ça veut
dire que pendant ce temps là il peut
aller à droite ou à gauche exact encore
une fois c'est un gros avantage car à
chaque foulée il a la possibilité de
changer de direction ou de modifier le
sens de l'action non
voilà pourquoi il doit faire autant de
contacts si barcelone a autant de succès
c'est à cause du nombre de contacts
autour de lui on sait qu'il doit faire
autant de contacts le côté magique de
barcelone même au ralenti il paraît
rapide on dirait qu'ils avancent à une
autre vitesse même au ralenti
contrôle à une vitesse hallucinante
c'est pareil quand il s'énerve sur
quelqu'un et qu'il fait un petit pont en
fait il pourrait tirer n'importe quand
mais il le fait pas il est tellement
rapide il fait ce qu'il veut quand il
veut l'autre jour il a marqué un but
iniesta passer la balle alexis sanchez
et mais s'il a récupéré au milieu du
genre excusez moi je peux la prendre il
a contrôlé avant de l'envoyer dans le
seul endroit où elle pouvait passer
voilà pourquoi il aimait si c'est de la
magie les endroits les plus étroits les
endroits les plus astucieux il sort le
lapin du chapeau pour marquer ou passait
en profondeur qui fait un changement à
30 mètres comme les coups francs les
coups francs par exemple
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui il est gaucher je sais mais son pied
droit ne lui sert pas seulement à
marcher il a souvent marqué du pied
droit très peu de gauche et son bon du
pied droit il est moins gauche et que
maradona dans le sens où maradona quand
il arrivait à se déporter sur la droite
faisait le coup du foulard est
d'utiliser un truc il devait inventer un
truc pour ne pas utiliser son pied droit
en revanche messi utilise son droit si
nécessaire un des pieds est toujours
meilleur que l'autre bien sûr mais si le
ballon vient de la droite il faut le
faire rentrer et tu ouvres beaucoup plus
si tu en es capable et dans la sélection
dans la sélection
il jouer librement de toute façon il
fallait le marc hé non c'est bien
entendu mais impossible de le laisser
seul mais on peut le remarquer de
différentes façons avec messi le un
contrat ça ne suffit pas il faut
toujours chercher le rhin contre 2
pour le marquer il faut oublier le
règlement non oui pas de coût mais
ça me fait mal quand il se fait tacler
ou quand ils tendent je ne supporte pas
ça
il est tellement précis il n'a pas
besoin de tirer fort parce qu'elle
rentre
le ballon part toujours sur le côté il
vise toujours le plus loin possible du
gardien il a battu tous les records un
coup du chapeau c'est banal pour lui
quand il marqué un seul but on trouvait
ça léger on était habitué à la normale
était normal surtout à l'entraînement je
pense que là les gens ratent beaucoup de
choses un vrai j'ai jamais envie de
jouer contre lui moi personne
les gens ils attendent quoi un double
salto avant le but
il a un avantage c'est que le public ne
voit pas la beauté du but seulement que
le ballon est rentré comment ça
intéresse qui que ce soit de l'intérieur
du pied un pointu ça peut être n'importe
quoi moi c'est ça qui me plaît et le
petit pont le double petit pont c'est un
peu pour la galerie c'est du circuit il
fait juste le nécessaire il est économe
dans le luxe il respecte l'adversaire il
peut aussi dépasser les limites non
parce qu'autrement on serait en train de
parler d'une statue bien sûr et pour des
bricoles parfois
quand léo est énervé quand il perd il
est insupportable toi aussi tu peux être
le roi des casse-pieds carette pas de me
tanner tu finis par me mettre hors de
moi c'est vrai
il a une seconde d'avancé sur le jeu si
vous ne savez pas qui est derrière vous
oui lui il le sait toujours la vision
panoramique tout vient l'adversaire la
position des coéquipiers l'espace
disponible pour manoeuvrer c'est un don
je pense que le grand tournant dans le
football espagnol a été le match madrid
barça la première année de mourinho un
match compliqué pour le barça bp s'est
fait expulser vous vous souvenez
l'herbe était haute entre autres je
crois que si madrid avait gagné ce match
et avait joué la finale de la champion's
league la face du football espagnol
aurait changé
mais si les a stoppés par une action
stratosphérique extraordinaire il s'est
emparé du ballon au centre du terrain il
a échappé à trois joueurs et il a marqué
un but incroyable
je crois que ça a mis fin au madrid de
mourinho même si madrid a gagné la liga
l'année suivante on sentait que le barça
était toujours aux commandes messi a été
absolument décisif il a dit dans ce
match c'est toujours nous qui réunion il
a gagné en jouant dans un style purement
maradonien selon moi on a assisté à un
moment quasi historique dont le football
espagnol des problèmes de madrid avec
barcelone et est surtout psychologique
je crois que dans ces matches messi a
pesé d'un poids absolument énorme c'est
sûr on sent que tout commence et finit
avec messi au moment où madrid va trop
loin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que tu sais faire don
[Musique]
tu vas devenir le plus grand joueur du
monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
a barcelone ils sont fatigués et ils
s'ennuient à force de gagner même si on
s'ennuie avec la joconde et qu'on
s'amusait à 8,1 d'une moustache tout à
fait laisser cette oeuvre d'art
[Applaudissements]
freiner c'est beaucoup plus important
que d'aller vite clairement il s'arrête
il pilote sur 2 cm et il repart mais
franchement t'as déjà vu une telle
vitesse ailleurs
oui ah bon la perle noire peut les
appeler pour m'appeler 7,1 à part
quand on parle football il ne faut
jamais évoqué pelé parce qu'il vient
d'une autre planète
il tient un peu de tous les grands
joueurs de l'histoire il a le contrôle
de zidane la vitesse dans naldo
une des premières fois où il a reçu le
ballon d'or j'ai ressenti une émotion
comme si c'était moi qui allais le
recevoir
[Musique]
j'ai pensé que ce qui lui est arrivé
était formidable j'étais tellement ému
que
j'ai pleuré oui je m'en souviens leo
messi pour la quatrième fois ballon d'or
c'est un géant ça ne fait aucun doute
aucun doute tu le vois déjà à tes côtés
dans l'histoire oui sans aucun doute il
est assis à la table de maradona enfin
la même table il est assis à la table de
10 t fans eaux de crue il est à la table
des grands ou pas est ce que vous vous
êtes mis d'accord pourquoi pour une mise
en scène une comédie dont je serai un
des personnages est là pour dîner ou
chercher dans tous vos commentaires à
faire des comparaisons vous rendez
compte ce qu'on voit là il le faisait
déjà trop petit il doit avoir sept ou
huit ans ils l'ont fait venir à la mi
temps d'un match de noël
il a fait 300 ou 400 jongle sans perdre
le ballon quand on regarde maradona puis
mais si on peut dire ils sont semblables
la différence c'est qu'il est beaucoup
plus petit oui
l'autre est plus mûr mais c'est pas un
showman diego par exemple avec l' orange
oui avec la boîte de conserve le range
le bouchon je pense que ça n'amuse pas
non c'est resté un garçon simple c'est
ce que je disais il n'aime pas s'exhiber
il a toujours été humble c'est ce qui
lui a permis d'en arriver là non
qui est ton idole parmi les joueurs
maradona
dacquois de maradona tu es gauche et tu
contrôles bien pourquoi tu l'admirent tu
veut limiter
non
et cela voilà le style dont je parle
toujours
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça ressemble tellement au but de
maradona contre les engrais identique
il couvre la même distance ils
rencontrent les mêmes obstacles sur sa
trajectoire
maradona joue plus sur les changements
de rythme on doit les feintes et parce
qu'il est moins rapide que mes cils
par contre messi est tout en
accélération
mais à la base ils sont très différents
les deux sont gauchers mais là est plus
rapide que l'autre
raja naqqash chabal la montre c'est une
autre époque un autre football d'autres
adversaires on ne peut pas comparer les
défenseurs anglais de l'époque avec ceux
d'aujourd'hui c'était il ya 30 ans c'est
impossible
maradona est un mythe n'est ce pas ce
qu'il a fait en 86 contre l'angleterre
après la guerre des malouines maradona
conduit une équipe tandis que les hôtes
définit la partie maradona lui même a
fait une excellente comparaison en
disant j'ai une meilleure vision du
terrain et les eaux une meilleure vision
des cages messines à messi possède ces
deux qualités à une auréole il porte son
équipe il insulte les supporters et il
siffle l'hymne national léo porte son
équipe en jouant oui en jouant s'impose
par son autorité naturelle les gens ses
coéquipiers par en tirant non il
n'impose rien messi est maradona mais
pas le maradona qu'on a pu voir parfois
on ici et maradona tous les jours non
chaque minute je me souviens de certains
matches de maradona à naples où il
semblait avoir disparu du terrain je
suis pas d'accord non non maradona
inventé naples et messi a inventé
barcelone
le messie a ajouté à cette oeuvre d'art
tout ce que vous voulez les yeux les
cheveux dernier coup de pinceau mais le
fc naples c'était une bande de types qui
couraient dans tous les sens jouer à
naples c'était la classe ouvrière
italienne qui patel et puissant de milan
maradona c'est une épopée toutes les
planètes étaient alignées voilà pourquoi
la comparaison est injuste réhausser les
eaux et diego c'est diego et les who
sera toujours les où il sera toujours
notre ami
si vous me demandez aujourd'hui qui est
le meilleur entre léo et diego je vous
répondrais mille fois les eaux je veux
pas me prononcer c'est mon opinion nous
les argentins on aime les comparez
surtout sur le nombre de buts semblables
qui l'ont marqué par exemple vous avez
vu celui avec la main non c'est aussi
avec la main regardez celui de léo avec
la main c'est le même que celui de
maradona incroyable
[Applaudissements]
maradona avait marqué ce but de la main
mais n'avait pas marqué l'autre but
personne ne se souviendrait de la main
non se souviennent du but de la main
parce que c'était contre les anglais
mais malgré cette main il a été le
meilleur joueur de toute cette coupe
c'est le même exactement c'est un
miracle et une chorégraphie
l'extravagance les excès de diego en
dehors du terrain il n'y a pas ça chez
les roux il faut faire taire marada
c'est négatif pour le personnage public
mais excellent pour le joueur diego a
beaucoup plus souffert dans sa vie ce
sont peut-être les erreurs que les eaux
ne fait pas qui le rendent meilleur
que maradona messi c'est l'argentin
qu'on aimerait être peut-être l'argentin
bien élevé qui part conquérir le monde
diego c'est l'argentin que nous sommes
un argentin plus bagarreur plus
excessifs et l'instar une relation avec
les gens
allez on ne s'est jamais fait exclure
sur une faute pendant une coupe du monde
j'arrête là les comparaisons tu t'en es
déjà chargé tu ne m'écoutes rappaz je
reste les bras croisés et je ne dis plus
rien parce qu'on peut tout comparer non
je ne compare pas je ne veux pas entrer
dans les comparaisons j'ai répété la
même chose mais mes cils ce sont deux
joueurs extraordinaires les meilleurs
joueurs du monde et meilleur joueur de
tous les temps mais que je n'aime pas
entrer dans les comparaisons
quand on lui pose la question il dit
qu'il ne faut pas les comparer à mon
avis maradona était meilleur mais je ne
sais pas pourquoi il était le meilleur
c'est le seul que je qualifie de
meilleur mais tous les suivants sur les
cracks
cas je remercie dieu que messi existe
s'il n'était pas là on parlerait encore
de maradona ce serait ridicule par
conséquent il ne faut pas comparer juste
en profiter on dit et on isole parmi les
joueurs maradona
les eaux je veux juste dire que je
t'aime beaucoup que tu assures
qu'ils laissent les autres dire
que tu seras le meilleur joueur de tous
les temps on en reparlera quand tu seras
en fin de carrière pour le moment fais
toi plaisir profite de ta famille je
t'aime beaucoup les eaux vraiment
messi n'a quasiment jamais mal joué mal
joué sur 100 matches que j'ai vus je les
ai vus mal joué trois fois c'est pas un
robot c'est un gamin je les ai vus
seulement deux fois se faire siffler par
le stade en copa america à santa fe et
au monumental contre la bolivie 1 contre
la bolivie l'élimination je crois que le
public a réagi contre l'équipe entière
quand une équipe joue affreusement mal
il ne s'en prennent pas à l'ailier droit
mais à la star le coup-franc tu t'en
souviens et comment il a tiré n'importe
où
il s'est fait siffler tant mieux s'ils
l'ont sifflé j'en aurais fait autant si
j'avais été son entraîneur lui aurait
dit je peux pas te laisser faire ça ne
recommence pas
[Musique]
pourquoi c'est surtout lui qui l'ont
sifflé ils ont sifflé l'équipe c'est lui
qui l'ont sifflé il est sorti sous les
sifflets c'est différent voilà c'est lui
qu'ils ont sifflé c'était un autre mais
si les gens répètent souvent ce qu'ils
entendent non une partie de la presse
s'est emparée de l'histoire les gens ont
cru qu'il ne s'impliquerait pas dans son
équipe il y avait des blagues sur messi
quand je parle avec les gens tél ils me
disent souvent qu'il est nul c'est une
bille ivoiriens j'ai toujours supporté
mais là c'est plus possible arrêter les
conneries c'est un mois que rien ce mec
là c'est une escroquerie j'étais très
mal quand ils ont commencé à le
critiquer tu en souffrent aussi le gamin
se décarcassent pour jouer en sélection
il le critique un touriste il se promène
sur le terrain rien à voir avec maradona
ne soyez pas méchant et lui ont reproché
de ne pas chanter l'hymne alors la prof
de musique je suis certaine de lui avoir
appris l'hymne national j'étais à santa
fe ont joué l'hymne national
[Musique]
tout le monde est lui aussi savait que
c'était injuste
[Musique]
bon pour cindy se sentait qu'il y avait
beaucoup d'émotion on pense à beaucoup
de choses il n'est pas obligatoire de
chanter l'hymne national pour être
argentin
je suis parti cinq minutes en avance
pour éviter d'entendre les commentaires
du public sur les ondes
quand les gens tombent là dedans c'est
d'une médiocrité épouvantable je ne
chante jamais alim
ça ne m'intéresse pas le plus important
ce qu'il n'a pas joué pour l'espagne
rien tout à fait qu'il a voulu jouer
pour l'argentine je me souviens qu'il a
dit a goal paix qu'il fallait arrêter de
le critiquer et le laisser tranquille il
a failli quitter la sélection qu'un jour
ils se fatiguent ray ne viendrait plus
pour le moment il vient toujours les
eaux et plus argentin que moi il a
toujours l'argentine et rosario dans la
tête revenir à rosario qui jouent et
profitez de toutes les choses dont il a
été privé enfants l'an messi vit en
espagne depuis ses 13 ans il parle
l'euro à rien et ne parle pas l'argentin
il parle le rose à rien a barcelone on
m'a dit que léo est un joueur qui quitte
rosario chaque matin
s'entraîne à barcelone et rentrer
ensuite en avion à rosario à la fin de
l'entraînement c'est au léo il est plus
argentin que le tango
[Applaudissements]
il ya eu un déclic dans la sélection
argentine
c'est le match de barranquilla c'était à
l'époque de sabella sabella est ici à
droite là il est là à partir de ce jour
là c'est devenu la sélection de messi et
messi a été le patron de cette équipe ça
a été le déclic il a peut être commencé
à jouer plus à sa façon qu'à celle que
tu avais imaginé
il arrive souvent dans le football que
certains matchs marque une étape
il faut essayer de comprendre chaque
joueur même si vous avez le meilleur
joueur du monde il faut essayer de le
comprendre mais ça messi est sorti
j'étais dans le vestiaire il m'a dit mon
jeu en sélection aujourd'hui il m'a dit
c'est le jeu que j'aime les passes
depuis les ailes et j'avais kun aguero
il avait plus d'options il est habitué à
ça au barça ce qui est intéressant c'est
que quand il n'est pas là
il est là
on croit qu'il n'est pas là
et il est là on croit qu'il n'est pas là
et tout à coup il s'empare du ballon et
fait un carnage tu resteras alejandro
comme l'entraîneur de la sélection qui
aura fait jouer messi comme à barcelone
on ne voulait pas l'admettre mais
maintenant c'est chose faite il a été
champion du monde avec les juniors est
aussi champion olympique être trois fois
champions et être le meilleur du monde
c'est le summum les gens disent souvent
il n'a pas gagné le mondial il a reçu
quatre ballons d'or et il est le seul
ouais mais en pointe toujours ce qui
vous manque exactement je pense qu'il
est le meilleur même sans être champion
je parle de sa carrière et s'est dit je
serais parfait avec une coupe du monde
un jour on reprendra les malouines avec
messi comme général et on lui reprochera
de ne pas porter une cocarde quand tu
fais une interview de messi c'est c'est
à mourir d'ennui c'est un pur esprit il
enfile les clichés comme des perles nous
jamais on ne découvrira quelque chose de
négatif sur lui
une époque les journaux on parlait des
problèmes fiscaux de léo envoyez-moi des
questions et j'y répondrai il a répondu
depuis l'hôtel de la sélection par mail
il est capable d'esquiver encore mieux
que sur le terrain c'est mon unique
interview par mail je suis un homme de
radio c'était une nouvelle expérience il
ya toujours des gens qui interfèrent ne
peuvent pas virer les masseurs de
confiance d'iniesta ou de xavi eux
peuvent le faire pas la direction il est
l'homme qui doit mettre fin à ça sk pas
messi est il capable de dire ce qui
convient à l'équipe ce qui est bon pour
le club doit-il ou ne doit-il pas le
faire la réponse ramon et oui je dis que
c'est oui c'est il a finit par s'isoler
et par changer de numéro de téléphone
sinon il était harcelée
depuis la coupe du monde je n'ai pas
parlé à léo non je ne lui parle je ne te
crois pas je ne voulais pas l'embêter
tout à fait on communique et puis j'ai
perdu
mon portable j'ai perdu mon portable wii
quand on est passé dans sa vie et qu'on
le voit courir on se dit une de ces
gouttes de transpiration m'appartiennent
pour nous c'est déjà un héros n'a plus
rien à nous prouver
le vent nous vers à messi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
témoin la grande rencontre on a vécu
tous les deux un moment très important
on devait avoir onze ou douze ans dans
ses agneaux et sa grand mère était
décédée
il m'a dit viens avec moi au cimetière
pour voir ma grand mère
je lui ai dit d'accord allons-y mais
c'est loin on était petit et on n'avait
aucune idée de ce qu'il y avait en
dehors de notre quartier
paris c'était terrible
ça a été une véritable odyssée à travers
ces quartiers très pauvres
les gens regardaient ces deux gamins
plus ou moins bien habillée
on a fini par atteindre le cimetière
pour voir sa grand mère
elle a eu une influence essentiel c'est
évident parce qu'elle lui a transmis un
certain optimisme c'est vrai lui a
transmis sans ce qui concernait son
obsession devenir joueur de foot il a
beaucoup souffert de sa disparition
[Musique]
on a mis des heures pour rentrer en état
on nous a demandé où on était partis
on a répondu on est allé voir la grand
mère de leo
vous imaginez le lien qu'il avait avec
sa grand mère pour aller la voir
tout en sachant que c'était dangereux de
quitter son quartier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bête
elle adorait le foot et la doua reste
une vraie fan
il aimait énormément sa grand mère c'est
certain elle n'a pas pu voir son
triomphe à chaque fois qu'il marque il
la remercie il la remercie le signe de
la victoire
[Musique]
voilà
on
monde
et
[Musique]